I mean he's he's an opinionist right so
I don't ever tell people how to how they
should feel about anyone I I know what
my experiences are with them Skip's
always been extremely generous with me
um a great mentor he's giving me some
some great advice over the years he's
gives strong opinions and sometimes most
of the time people are going to disagree
with your opinion right that's what the
opinion space is so I don't really find
that it's particularly unique to just
skip because I've worked with Skip and
I've worked with Shannon and I've worked
with Colin and I work with other
opinionists now and I worked with big
Personalities in Miami
that's what you're doing if you're
giving your opinion the reality is most
people aren't going to like what you
have to say I mean I deal with it now I
get my opinion every day I know people
aren't going to like what I have to say
sometimes right and that's fine because
that's what my opinion is now I think my
delivery is maybe a little cheekier than
skips but you know that's that's his
style and he's he's okay with people
disagreeing with him